and we are back with the wonderful
nicole richie
and by the way it's always so exciting
in business when you can keep your
promises that's what neon
you know my partner my the love of my
life other than my daughters
she would always say keep your promises
if people allow
you to use their money and take a chance
on you in business keep your promises
and you're crushing it for quibby right
now
and it's so great because then you know
it's like nice when it works for
everybody and you get to keep your job
and they're thrilled it's like
then then it's good business as well as
a wonderful creative opportunity
yeah i think you know obviously just
just like you were saying like sometimes
you have to
create your own roles or you know what i
think i think
whatever you're doing whether it's
designing or
acting you want to be in a tv show or
you want to read a book it's like
actually a lot of that stuff comes from
the person saying to themselves ah i
wish there was a story about this
or oh i wish like even with me like with
house of harlow it's i
you know i used to be like i wish i had
like a kimono you know like
you know you just think about things
that you would want that don't exist and
you're like well i guess then
i will go and create it myself or write
it myself you know
and i think to have those moments you
know
are they come they're few and far
between
so you know when you have that creative
spark it's important to just
run after it take advantage of it i
think that is
excellent advice because you're an
amazing brander
and then the show has proven to be
successful
for you and quibby and everybody's
loving it and i think that's a good
thing
you know to sort of strike while the
iron is hot grab that
inspiration when you have it you always
think in a dream you're going to
remember
in the morning and sometimes you don't
so i'm equating it to that metaphor
go after it and catch those butterflies
in your net i i remember you saying
something to me along the lines of um
that even like when you were looking for
roles like they just weren't really
written for you and that's that's why
you had to start making them yourself
yeah and no one called me
i didn't have directors like i would
love to work with her it just didn't
happen every once in a while i would get
the fortune of
working with someone i really looked up
to and respected but for the most part
that phone did not ring
so i was like i'm gonna build the
telephone
and call people with that telephone and
make it ring
for myself but really it became so much
about like creating
jobs for you know a lot of different
people
in the goal of wanting to make fun
things because you can't make anything
alone
yep exactly and i love what you're doing
with nikki fresh and i've been listening
to all these
uh radio shows about how nurturing
for so many syndromes that gardening is
and people did victory gardens back in
the day and i do think that you are
always ahead of the game and on the
pulse with your gardening and you are so
cool
and you are you know from obviously
musical legendary family and you're
married into that and oh my god by the
way
your sister-in-law i mean that's what
really also
we had already that's what brought us
together that's what brought us together
cameron diaz again not to name drop is
your sister-in-law
and my one of my oldest and i just
i love you nicole you are such a cool
fun
hip mellow aware with it you just you
are the complete package
and i can't wait to wrap my arms around
you and get our beardies together
same do they they don't have to social
distance i feel like
i don't feel like i i think by the way
this one's solo
it she needs she needs speedy so as soon
as it's appropriate we're going to get
them together
okay okay perfect thank you nicole nicky
fresh thank you
i love you so much all episodes of nikki
fresh are streaming on quibby
and her new album unearthed is available
right
[Music]
now
you